[Music]
a car's dashboard is full of dials and
gauges that keep the driver up to speed
on everything
in the time of the horse and buggy a
dashboard was a wooden panel for
shielding the driver from mud and water
hence the word dash which can mean
bespatter or splash
[Music]
when motorized vehicles came along
instruments were added making the
dashboard an important source of
information
today's dashboards tell the driver a lot
at a glance
ignore the indicator dials and you could
run out of fuel or be slapped with a
speeding ticket
a dashboard for a luxury sports car
starts with this aluminum skeleton it's
been bonded at the joints with adhesive
that's stronger than conventional welds
a technician clips the main electrical
harness to the aluminum frame
he then fixes the heating and air
conditioning unit to the center of the
dashboard skeleton and connects it to
the wiring
at the next station the dashboard's
composite substructure is coming
together
working from the back the technician
installs a glove box and a network of
ducts for the heating and cooling system
the substructure is now ready to join
the wired aluminum frame
he rivets the assembly to the metal
structure
he slots the driver's information module
which includes the speedometer into the
housing
[Music]
he equips the dashboard with high-end
speakers
the front passenger airbag encased in
aluminum comes next
the technician inserts it in the molded
plastic niche
using a computerized tool he installs
the airbag with perfect precision
next up is the steering column with its
magnesium shifting paddles and wiper
controls already attached
he slides it into place just under the
information module he then encases the
electronics with plastic cowling
this both protects the wiring and tucks
it out of sight
he tops off this job with more cowling
above
[Music]
he adds a hand-stitched leather surround
to the dashboard's center console
he inserts the center stack which
contains the radio other audio equipment
and temperature control mechanisms more
leather adds a luxurious look smell and
feel to the cabin
the next technician assembles push
button controls for shifting gears
he installs them in a veneered fascia
through the back to avoid damaging the
glossy finish on the front
he inserts vents for air conditioning
and heating above the gear shift
controls
again sliding them into place through
the back of the unit
he secures the vents with screws
then adds the starter assembly
the satellite navigation system gets the
top spot which will put it with an easy
eye shot once installed in the dashboard
with the sub-assembly almost complete he
flips it around it needs one finishing
touch
a chrome and glass casing for the
starter
he slides it into place and the unit is
now ready for the dashboard
[Music]
he makes all the right connections and
installs the gadget-filled fascia just
over the center stack
he now encases the rest of the dashboard
in leather paneling this particular
panel has a built-in split so it will
part if the airbag deploys
next a technician downloads computer
software for all the equipment in the
dashboard
he configures the electronics to the
appropriate settings
he then tests each component confirming
that every instrument and control works
perfectly
this dashboard now joins all the others
ready to take their place in the front
of a luxury sports car
a modern dashboard can define a car's
interior space and add serious gadget
appeal
for example this car uses a distinctive
steel and crystal key for the engine
ignition
when the key slot glows red there's
power
it's time to press a few buttons and see
what pops up like this speaker for
example
with a high-tech luxury dashboard a
driver can really travel in style
[Music]
you